[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Max Duggan the TCU
quarterback who do you think should win
the Heisman
you know whoever they vote for
well who would you vote for
you know they're all you want the
political politically correct answer no
no no I do you think you're the you're
the best candidate
you know I don't know I I don't really
think about it too much on uh
came from my Dad tried to be a whole guy
they're all great players you know if I
would be able to get voted and win it
you know it would be a tremendous award
but you know they're all really really
good players well I think just getting
there is pretty amazing if if you look
back in the spring where you weren't
even going to be the starting
quarterback
yeah I wasn't yeah
and what was your reaction to that
yeah you know I I was uh it was
disappointing in my eyes you know they
you know when the job was disappointed
myself but uh you know I wanted to help
the team I want to be here at TCU when
we were winning and helped this team you
know get back to you know being talked
about on National level
what hurts today after that game
you know
um obviously body wise there's a lot but
you know within you know there's a lot
of emotion you know you you go in
undefeated season you know you want to
win a conference Championship League
Championship and you lose that game so
closely you know our last second field
goal
um there's a lot of emotion but you know
we get opportunity to go compete for a
national championship so
you're out of breath after you ran the
touchdown but you just you can't call
timeout you've still got the two-point
conversion how gassed were you
yeah I was pretty tired uh you know I
had a couple long runs on that drive but
you know I was trying to do whatever we
could to try to make a play try to give
us a shot to you know maybe to get a
two-point conversion set into overtime
but yeah I was pretty winded after the
after that drive okay explain to me what
happened then uh in overtime that you
didn't get the ball those last two plays
uh could you have changed the plays if
you wanted to at the line of scrimmage
yeah so we went in with two plays that
we felt you know pretty good good about
you know places I've been successful for
us obviously we're giving it to Kendra
our running back that you know has been
successful a lot this year especially
down the one yard line
um you know run a run scheme to you know
where our guys you know we're we're
confident in and you know Kansas State
made two good plays you know they
stopped us at the one both times
um doesn't happen a lot but you know
credit to them what do you know about
Michigan
yeah you know you know they're a
phenomenal team great team will Coach
they got you know dudes all over their
field whether it's on offense defense
you know they they run the ball well
throw the ball well you're not going to
get a lot of shots uh not a lot of
opportunities defensively you know they
play their game they're big they're
athletic
um they're gonna make things difficult
on if they trust their guys on the back
end so it's gonna be fun
how'd you get invited to the Mavs game
last night
yeah so it was a family member of mine
yeah so I went with them
and obj was there last night
yeah Houston courtside
you didn't get Court signed no I didn't
get Courtside I'm not on that level if
you win the Heisman you're gonna get
Courtside there yeah maybe did you talk
to obj no I wasn't able to see him I
just uh they put him up on the Jumbotron
all that I think you send a send by
Micah and Diggs I think did you meet
Luca I did not no I was not I was not
given anything what the heck is going on
here Max I was I was just with a family
member you know invited me to the game
you know what if you wore your jersey if
you wore your uniform that might have
helped you maybe get a little a little
preferential treatment maybe who do you
model your game after
you know I don't know if there's a
single person that I really modeled my
game after
um you know I grew up a I grew up a
Green Bay fan so you know you watched
Barb and Aaron Rodgers and try to be
that kind of Gunslinger you know
different arm angle still work trying to
make that play
um other guys in the league you watch
you know like Joe burrow what he does
with you know pocket mobility and uh
movements inside the pocket of being
quick try to you know go off of that you
take you know Kyler and Russell in the
Run game of you know making plays with
their feet and being Dynamic so there's
a lot of things you kind of you know
pick and choose that you want to take
from guys to try to put into your own
game
you know you go back to that covid test
that you took if you don't take that
covid test
what do you think happens
yeah I don't really know what happens
yeah I think I probably go on the rest
of my life a couple years and you know
there's probably bigger implications
that happen to me when I'm you know kind
of older and
um you know out of Athletics you know
not as in shape things that sort you
know getting up there and you know I I
really don't know what happened I really
kind of want to imagine it so
well I mean you had a nine hour heart
surgery procedure because you test
positive for covid but then what did
they tell you after you tested positive
yeah so I test spots for kova and then
you know in college athletics they did
uh put all these heart screenings to
their time they're worried about the
mitochonditis I think was what was going
on in covid yeah so they have you do EKG
you know ultrasound on your heart all
these tests and then when they did the
EKG they found you know a little
um you know Wolf Park is the white
standards what I have it shows up on EKG
pretty easily so
um they kind of saw it maybe go through
a couple other tests and then
um had to kind of sit me down and tell
her what was going on
did you know if you could play football
yeah initially I didn't really
um I thought you know when they say you
have a heart issue you know it's pretty
serious you have to have surgery I
thought you know football was probably
over so
well got a big game coming up against uh
Michigan and do you have the outfit
picked out for the Heisman Trophy
ceremony
yep I got one picked out so there's a
you know a little shop down here in Fort
Worth that you know got me right okay
what what are we going with though
because we're going to be seeing this
for years and years and years to come so
yeah no it'll be uh it'll be a good
little tribute to TCU it'll get on
Saturday so yeah you'll be able to see
it okay A little little purple in there
yes sir all right are you getting your
hair cut before the Heisman Ceremony
yeah I need to yeah my Mom's starting to
get on me about it so I think I'm about
to cut it I don't think you mess with
the street like you're on here I think
you say that you don't want me you want
me to talk to Mom and just tell her hey
come on Samson Samson didn't cut his
hair yeah yeah my Mom's starting to call
me and you know give me some angry phone
calls about my hair when she sees
pictures
well congrats on the great season there
and uh good luck against Michigan and
the Heisman Ceremony yeah appreciate it
thanks for having me on it's Max Duggan
he is uh one of the four Heisman Trophy
finalists there we don't want
politically correct answers you think
you're the best candidate tell me